this is Gary mcke this is West Cumbria
where Gary went on his daily
run he'd usually go past these sheep
past his primary
school and past bill who would Brew him
a cup of tea then he'd run back home
before work seems pretty idic right
until you realize Gary's morning run is
a marathon that's 26.2 mil a every
single
[Music]
day I'm Gary mcke and in 2022 around 365
marathons in 365 days the story probably
starts on the 23rd of June 1997 when I
came home from work and when I went in
the house my dad was sitting there in
his usual chair and he had tears in his
eyes he told me that he had cancer he
passed away 6 years later of under
illness and in his memory I wanted to do
something to celebrate his life so I
became a fundrais for McMillan cancer
support knowing that the Charities were
going into people's houses and telling
them the same devastating years that
we've been told Gary raised money by
doing long-distance running but he
wanted to take his challenges to the
next level it all just happened really
quick we were sat in the kitchen I was
painting his face and he just he just
came out with it we were all shocked
I'm sure there are other people who have
done something similar in terms of
marathons but not while holding down a
full-time job to do it whilst running a
a family a busy family life and still
supporting other people along the way
there actually aren't any
words Gary ran around 10,000 miles over
the year that's the distance between
Rome and
Sydney he spent 30 hours running every
week in one of the hilliest parts of
England climbing the equivalent of 11.7
Mount Everest over the year if I was
going to work I'd be up at 5:00 in the
morning the only things I wouldn't know
would be my shoes I'd never wore the
same pair of shoes on consecutive days
and then I would normally do
motivational video for the deer good
morning on day 289 10° outside cloudy
and
windy word caught on quickly once people
started to realize this madman was
actually running 26 miles every single
day they began to join him to support
the cause people were coming previously
couch to 5 care 5K to 10 care 10 care to
half marathon pushing themselves to do
the full Marathon work colleague Chris
ran 92 marathons alongside Gary over the
year Gary's challenge gave me a purpose
at the time that I needed it most
sometimes I don't really know the best
way to help myself but I always know
that trying to help others is the best
way to start I don't think any of us
would have went I'm going to run even in
excess of 10 marathons in a
year it was December 31st
2022 the 365th marathon Gary's final day
was a Monumental occasion a 50 strong
band of Runners joined Gary on a Victory
lap the town was alive with
energy the final day I mean what an
event that was the procession that
followed Gary through Cur absolutely
incredible just before we finished I
pulled everybody together and I thanked
them and I said to them no matter how
many miles you run in your life you'll
always remember this last
one the roads are lined with people his
fireworks going off and there was over a
th people the club waiting for me coming
in and just chocolate
block at 7:20 p.m. Gary had reached his
fundraising goal the Manel as of now has
raised 1 million for m h at
[Music]
home
what you've got to remember is I hadn't
had a bay for over a year so being the
extreme person I am I tried to do a 26.2
[Music]
bers I think if people understood what
their actual limits were and what the
boundaries were they would say that they
could push themselves a lot further than
the believe I think it's getting
comfortable being uncomfortable
sometimes and just working towards the
light because however dark it is is you
can always find the light if you dig
deep
[Music]
enough